alright thanks folks thanks for this
stay sticking with us through the
afternoon
it's April 20 it's a little bit after
4/20 now I was actually thinking I
should change my job to something about
like THC contradict concentration
analysis but we're gonna do something
just as fun we're gonna play minecraft
and just before I get into it I'm just
gonna jump in and make sure nothing is
going to sleep on me while we've been
getting ready like Minecraft servers
running I'm gonna connect over into our
and make sure I can connect to it and by
the way that is my IP address for my
minecraft server if you want to go in
the world and troll me while I'm talking
feel free but let's start off with the
oily one thing I've did that it's
raining in the world I don't want that
let's stop for raining where they're
clear I think it's the command there we
go alright sorry let's start off fact
let's start off with the world so this
is minecraft I don't know if you've seen
minecraft if you have a teenage daughter
or son it's likely you have if not it's
just a fun open-world environment you
can play in survival mode which means
that a bunch of zombies will come and
attack you I'm playing it in creative
mode which basically makes it into 3d
Lego and you can build all sorts of
structures and play around and dig and
in this particular case I've got a
little pumpkin here sitting on a stand
and if I hit that pumpkin nothing
happens because I forgot to run the
script let me go back up here that was
such an exciting demo we're gonna put
the block back in the world and run a
little loop in ah which is gonna do some
stuff and there's my punchline alright
there's the block back and now when I
hit the block welcome to New York our
conference yeah alright
so I actually wanted to use this to do
all of my slides in Minecraft but I got
a bit lazy and I just have my title
slide but let let's talk a little bit
about it so like I said minecraft it's a
really fun 3d exploration and building
game if you have kids you've probably
seen it it was developed by Mojang who
was acquired by Microsoft in 2014 and I
pointed it out simply because it gives
me the justification for having spent
the last few days playing Minecraft at
work kids do amazing amazing things with
Minecraft they get in the world and
build all sorts of things like this is
the red keep in Westeros you know
rendered in the Minecraft world and they
spent hours upon hours upon hours doing
this and what we thought and
particularly cow broman who you can see
over here thought was why can we use
this enthusiasm the kids have for
playing in the Minecraft world and
rather than building up a wall brick by
brick by brick
perhaps we can convince them to learn a
programming language namely ah so that
they could rather write a function to
build that wall for them and in the
process learn how to do programming so
at the our open site hackathon in Los
Angeles last year which was a really
really fun and awesome hackathon we got
together six of us to put together an
hour package with a bunch of simple
functions that kids could use to build
up more elaborate scenes and scenarios
and actions within the Minecraft world
this was inspired by a book that Cowell
had that he'd given to his daughter
could learn to program with Minecraft
which was based in Python and we thought
to give our equal opportunity we should
create a similar kind of package in our
that will provide these functions for
kids to do these really cool things the
book provides a bunch of recipes for
doing all sorts of tasks like you know
build a staircase by writing a function
in Python and I'm going to show you how
you can do that same thing using these
packages in our the thing that makes all
this possible is the architecture of the
original Minecraft program where there's
a server that's running which basically
represents the state of the world
and in my car in my case I'm going to be
running that server on a bun to virtual
machine which is running in the cloud
and then there's a client which is what
gives you or the flashy graphics or
flashy if you consider those blocks to
be flashy but that's the thing that
actually renders the world for the point
of view of the player accepts the
players motions and commands and then
sends those back to the server which
then updates the board accordingly so
the way our package in our is going to
work is it's going to modify the world
at the server side and then they'll be
rendered in the client whose player
we're in they're playing Minecraft and
you can do all this yourself the server
is open-source
it's called spigot and you can download
it from all sorts of docker repositories
and I'll show you how to do that you do
require something called the raspberry
juice plugin which provides the API that
we're going to interface in from the odd
language you're also going to need the
minecraft program on your PC
unfortunately as thing stands right now
you can't use the Xbox or the mobile
versions you need to doubt and not the
Windows Store version but if you buy any
of those you also get access to the
original Mojang version which is a
java-based application and you need to
sign up for an account at Mojang don't
come to do that but basically once
you've got everything set up you've got
the server running in a remote server
you've got the minecraft application
running on your desktop you've got a
third PC which in this case is going to
be the same as the one that are running
minecraft on which is going to run these
packages I mentioned miner and Kraft
which are going to modify the world so
we've actually provided two packages to
do all this stuff the base package which
we put together at the our open site
hunk conference was called miner and
this provides very very simple building
blocks to interact with the server like
connect to the server through an IP
address have a look at the world by
seeing which blocks are rendered in
their available rather in the 3d world
and monitor the play so you can find the
location in the player which way they're
facing if they're hitting blocks all
that stuff is available as very basic
functions and that package is available
on github right now then for those sort
of high-level projects this idea are
saying building a stack
we wrote a separate package which
encapsulates some of these simple
functions put together the idea is the
kids would write those things themselves
if they want to jump right in and have
some fun they can access some
higher-level functions which are
available in the craft package which
also has an Associated book which is
written in book down and they can sort
of go through all the steps of how these
higher-level activities were created and
the lunar on the way by having a look at
that book and a particular shade out
shout out to Kyle brew man who put
together a lot of the content for that
book alright and in fact here's the book
there's the link where you can find it
and read it it's called our program with
Minecraft and you can see if you have a
look at the section on the left-hand
side all the things you can do you know
build a staircase build a rainbow build
a tower plant a garden you know all
sorts of things that the kids might want
to have fun doing they can either write
themselves or just use the recipes that
are available in this book all right now
for you if you want to play with all of
this it's actually pretty easy to get
things set up one of the things that is
provided in the instructions for the
miner package is a docker file if you
haven't used docker it's been mentioned
a few times in the talks today it's a
really convenient way of basically
setting up all the components in sort of
a virtual machine in this case that
involves setting up raspberry juice
within spigot setting up all the ports
to open up the connections to the
minecraft server instead of doing that
manually just by using this docker file
you can then generate a server in just a
couple of seconds and all the
instructions are showing you to show you
how to do that are available in the
miner package all right in my particular
case I'm setting up the server as a
virtual machine within Asia and then
rucking running docker within that
virtual machine the specific virtual
machine I used to do that is something
called the data science virtual machine
this is a really handy collection of all
sorts of open source tools including
things like R and Python already set up
in the virtual machine but it also
includes some things that is
particularly useful for this project
which is number one docker itself which
I used to run the docker file which then
loads in all of the Minecraft stuff that
I need and also provides the Tmax
application which is real
handy for me when SSH drops the
connection and my minecraft server dives
you'll see that in a second when I get
into it also you might want to run this
command in spigot after you get things
up things up called default mode
creative because otherwise within a few
minutes you'll be overrun with zombies
and all the work you're doing is wasted
alright so - once you've got everything
set up you've got the server running in
the cloud or even on a local machine you
can just install those two packages from
github so you can use Hadleys dev tools
package to install them directly from
github as you can see there then use the
miner library this function NC connect
connects our to the running minecraft
server and then you can do su all sorts
of things in there and that's what you
saw me do just a second ago when I wrote
a little script called RC which is
connect to the server and read a little
message so I made sure all my
connections are working the connections
do tend to expire for about 10 minutes
so you might see me reconnecting if it's
decided to disconnect while I've been
sitting here chatting so there all sorts
of functions that are available to you
in the craft package - to modify the
world based on these sort of lower level
functions just to modify individual
blocks for example when you saw me plop
up the message that said welcome to NY
our conference all I did there was
figure out where the player was standing
we had to get player pause function and
then used a couple of functions that are
available in the craft package to write
some text up in space welcome to New
York our conference and having done that
and because I'm in creative mode I can
sort of fly all around the space you can
see that these are just blocks
they've been rendered in the 3d world
and you can kind of do anything you want
with them it's the rain back again
where that I would clear alright there
we go alright so let's have a look what
else we can do
so with those funk that the basic
building blocks of those functions you
can do things like I said we already
seen get the play position you can also
set blocks which means put things in the
world and there are different types of
blocks there's stone and there's wood
and there's ice in this glass and
there's gold and all sorts of things we
have a fun example which I meant to do
with Jared's photo and I didn't get
around to it in time but you can take
somebody's picture and then render it as
different colored blocks so you can
actually see the picture in the
Minecraft well that's kind of fun here's
another fun one you can actually do this
sort of dynamically as the player is
moving around in the world just by using
a while loop in the arc function I'll
show you how this works in just a second
so what I can do is I can go into R I'm
gonna have a look at my scripts yeah I'm
gonna put a couple of blocks in the
world just to give me a starting point
like I did before with the pumpkin all
right
then I'm gonna run a while loop which
just has a look at the block the player
is standing on well actually no sorry
it's the while loop is just to sit and
watch if the player triggers things by
like cutting a block but that little
stood for lip you can see right there
what it's doing is it's having a look at
hoops I got an error message of that
that's not a see that's what happens
when it disconnects do that again
so I've ever turn an air that's not good
at all
this is fun watching we could live and
let's see what's happening in the world
alrighty has returned to normal
alright one more try and then I gonna
give up cuz this is really fun to watch
so let's set a couple of blocks in the
world so what should have happened at
that point is we have a block of ice
we're on top of a little blue block
there and we can wait for the player
district
while announcer do those things all
right now it's ready that's thing I
destroyed the block too early because
what was supposed to happen was when I
click on this block it suddenly says you
have the power of Elsa and now what I
can do is as I run around the world and
as you can see there's a bit of water
over here as I get near the water all
right I give up what I was supposed to
do was it's really cool it was supposed
to like ice appears under her feet and
you're Elser and then you can stop it
but I give up if you want to see it
later on I'll be over there and you can
see what happens all right hopefully my
other demo works that's the fun one all
right one of the things you might have
seen was messages that popped up that
said you have the powers of L so you can
send messages to the players with the
chat post function you could also grab
the messages that the players send
between themselves with get check posts
because the players when they're all in
the world together often chat to each
other and that lets you do fun things
and this is in the crafts book of do
things like you know number guessing
games you can say guess the number
between 1 and 100 and all the players
will type different numbers and as soon
as somebody guesses the right number you
pull that out with chat posts and give
them a nice message and that's a fun
little game but the one I wanted to show
you was the one I've been playing around
with a couple last couple of days
justifying my work because this is a
Microsoft thing was to write a little
function in ah that would generate a
maze so I've got a function called Jen
maze it turned out there were actually a
couple of packages already on cran for
generating mazes in R but they're all
based on these all huge complicated you
all network algorithms so whatever just
run sprite something simple that kids
could do so I just went back and did a
simple recursive generative maze
function just the basic computer science
101 and now when I have these two
functions I can do maze is make maze 10
5 and you can see print this amazing
ASCII which isn't very exciting but what
I could do then is render that maze in
the Minecraft world and we can play in
the maze
so let's go back to my script yeah
so the first thing I do is going to
generate a maze I'm gonna put there's
altitude of that is how high in the wood
I wanted to go and choose a couple of
corners for it in a clear sense space in
the world alright so what we should find
now is when we look I'm still in the
water over here we've got some space
cleared which I think it's gonna be over
there yeah I can see a big hole all
right am I going to add a floor for the
maze and then just loop through the 15
by 15 maze I created and put some blocks
on there all right there it is so we can
go over fly into the maze and now let's
see if I can solar this is a randomly
generated maze so I don't actually know
where to go and it actually turns out
like this isn't a very big maze but I
played with this a bit and it's
surprisingly difficult to actually solve
these when you can't look from above
which you can't actually do function if
I'm there we go there we go I can sort
of look from above like this and that
makes things a bit easier but more
challenging would be is how can we write
a little robots that's gonna solve that
maze itself a little fun little exercise
so I just wrote a little function which
uses the left hand rule to choose which
way to go I won't go through the details
of this all of this will be in my blog
when I write it up next week and then we
can just write a little thing that
checks if it's fits got to the end of
the maze where I put a torch just so you
can see the end and I will just follow
the left hand rule as it moves around
the world oh it's decided it's sold it
already all right let's try it again now
all right
oh my demo is failing this is so
embarrassing all right one more try
let's it's all work when I tried it like
ten minutes again sold iterate alright
anyway come and come to the come to the
booth over there I'll be I can show you
it all that running but let's go to the
end
all right so if you want to play around
this like I said it's all available
there on github github.com
RF and Scilab slash miner the book is at
the link you can see on the screen right
there as well and that craft package
which implements the thing like doing
Elsa and the mazes is also available
that link right there and if you would
like to come and play online my server
is running now at the IP address you see
right there thanks very much
[Applause]
you